MALE SPEAKER: In this video I'll
show how to make output
invisible, which is helpful when
a function has a large
output, and I'll also cover
how to use a function
recursively.
If your function returns a lot
of results, it might be a bit
obnoxious when a person forgets
to assign the output
to an R object.
If you think your output is
likely to be annoying when
it's printed out, you can use
the Invisible Function in
place of the Return function.
Then when a user fails to save
the result to an R object,
their console will not be
flooded with output.
And if they do assign the
output to an object, the
object will store the result.
That said, invisible output can
confuse users, so use this
trick with caution.
It's also worth noting that
using classes and methods
inside of R is another way to
address this challenge.
However, classes and methods
aren't topics I'll cover in
this video.
And one more tip before
we move on
to recursive functions.
If you happen to flood your
console screen, or if you
simply want to clear the
council, if you're on a Mac,
use Command Alt L, or if you're
on Windows, Control L,
which will clear your
console screen.
All right, on to recursive
functions.
A recursive function as a
function that may call itself.
For example, I can create a
function called LogMe, that
takes the log of a value if the
value is larger than 1,
and keeps doing this until
it gets a value
that's less than 1.
If the value is less than 1,
then the function simply
returns the result.
The way the code is written
works, but what if I happen to
change the function's name?
I would still want the function
to call itself.
To make sure it does, I should
use the function called
Recall, which automatically
calls the function it's in.
In general, using Recall is
the preferred way to build
recursive functions in R. In the
next video, we'll look at
how to use a custom function
with the Apply function.